قد يتفاجا الزائرون لمدينه اسطنبول بهذه
البساتين وقد يعتقد انها زرعت في غفله من
الدوله وبعيدا عن رقابتها فهي تمتد
بمحاذاه الاسوار الاثريه العريقه للمدينه
بيد انها تاريخ هذه الاراضي الزراعيه يعود
الى حقبه الرومان الذين سمحوا بزراعتها في
زمن السلم وهو ما اقره العثمانيون واستمر
الى يومنا هذا كارث ثقافيه وتاريخي»
على هذا التقليدي لعشرات السنين لكنه لا
ينظر بكثير من التفاؤل الى مستقب لهذا
المكان
يدك الابوصه
لا يمكن تخيل الصور دون هذه البساتين التي
يمتد عمرها الى 10500 عام وبلديه اسطنبول
هي التي تناسق عملنا هنا فنحن نحمي
الاسوار لكن مشكلتنا اليوم ان ابنائنا غير
متحمسين لاكمال ما بداؤه اجدادنا
فريد مزارعون افغاني يعمل في بساتين سور
اسطنبول منذ نحو اربع سنوات هو احد
المهاجرين الذين استعان بهم اصحاب
البساتين في ظل عزوف الشباب
تاريخي ولا يمكننا استخدام الالات الحديثه
ومن يلتحقون بالعمل معنا يتركوننا بعد
ايام حديقه مزارع سور اسطنبول تحتوي على
خمس وثلاثين قطعه ارض صغيره بعدد المدارس
الابتدائيه في المنطقه وكل مدرسه مسؤوله
عن زراعه وحصاد قطعتها
يتدربوا الاطفال هنا على مراحل الزراعه
المختلفه وكل هذا في الحديقه التي اقامتها
على مطلوبه من الاسوار بلديه حي الفاتح
التي تقع المنطقه التاريخيه ضمن حدودها
الاداريه
هدفنا الرئيسي ان نعرف اطفال المدينه على
رحله نبته من البذره الى الثمره وان نقوي
علاقتهم بالارض وبتاريخ مزارع السور
اسطنبول
بانهم يقدمون منتجا زراعيا عضويا من داخل
هذه المدينه المزحمه لكنهم يخشون ان تتحول
اراضيهم في يوم من الايام الى حدائق عامه
زراعيه في قلب واحده من اكبر مدن العالمي
واكثرها بالسكان ارتباطها بهذا المكان
التاريخي ساعد على استمرارها لمئات السنين
لكن بالرغم من محاولات ربط الاجيال
القادمه بهذا التقليدي القديم يبدو انه
غدا مهددا بالاندثار اسطنبول